him he's got good things to say
journalist's biggest blind spot
in coverage is groupthink we draw from a
limited pool of people who generally
have a similar background in class
simply aren't able to see the
perspective of people who are not like
them and tend to drive out those who
won't fit in
these are the writing responses will for
ignorance and distaste
for views that don't support our own the
environment how income inequality racial
equality influence society politics
interesting
yeah exactly coverings from the
benefactors there's there's
you know uh none of toughness then too
much this is
um it's useful because it's actually
like kind of an internal admission
and it's as representative of a survey
as one is going to get and i think
the issue that people have been stuck in
is they've been stuck in this um
you know false dichotomy of
oh you know like journalism is bad oh we
need
you know good journalism though so we
need to fund the same thing more
but a paradigmatically different
approach is rather than having
one journalist making let's say a
hundred thousand dollars a year
you have um a hundred people who make a
thousand dollars a year
part-time they've got day jobs but
they have one or two or three articles a
year and they make a thousand bucks from
that
yeah and it's it's kind of something
which is like the sub stack model for
example
yeah and you essentially decentralize
journalism
and you make it a large enough class
that it's harder for them to collude
and they actually are the citizenry who
are popping up to speak their mind and
they actually have
domain knowledge when they do so you
know what it's already happened if you
look at podcasting i think
the reason podcasting has become so
prominent
is that people are looking at link
baiting and they don't trust the media
media's at an all-time low
the picking of size the tribalism it
makes people just feel icky
and they feel like it's just not healthy
and then when they
listen to a joe rogan podcast and they
watch him interview bernie sanders
or whoever he happens to be interviewing
for two hours or three hours or you and
i are doing an hour and a half
you feel like i got a pretty good sense
of what's going on here
uh or a better sense and i can really
let the person
unpack what they're saying and you as
the subject like how do i misrepresent
you in this podcast i'd have to do some
post production
and really screw with the audio and i
always tell people we don't
the only thing we'll ever take out of
the audio is if you told us there was
something you said that you regret and
you reasonably don't want to be
misunderstood and we're like yeah we
don't want you to be misunderstood well
and that's happened twice in a thousand
episodes i think somebody said
something they felt would be
misconstrued they made a joke about
communism or something and
they didn't want to be crass no it's a
true story it happened this year
um and so i i don't know what do you
think do you think podcasting is
reaction to this
in some ways or a solution maybe yeah so
i think
actually podcasting is part of it um so
let me give
my kind of ten ish pointers on it may
not actually add up to ten let's say n
pointers on um how to decentralize media
um so one of them is every company a
media company
and uh what i mean by that is
we we need to go from content marketing
to full stack narrative
and the entire podcast thing that vcs
have been doing
is essentially the burgeoning of you
know what i think of as the west coast
media ecosystem
where it's not just text uh or audio
but it should soon become movies um
and and everything basically tell your
whole story
and um there's a there's a site
uh which has like 110 100 um
it's called uh gosh what's the name of
this site um
which is making videos uh wistia w-i-s-t
yeah i know where's the a-i-u yeah so
wistia gives a good
i think a great example of what
full-stack narrative looks like
and full stack narrative is um
you do not have to go to somebody else
for uh for distribution i mean for
example
um rachel maddow doesn't appear on
laura ingram's show or vice versa right
um typically
they have their own show exactly and so
that's related to kind of premise
numbers so first every company a media
company
and relates to that build your own
distribution
to avoid distortion you need
basically you know for tech companies
and for more more broadly but the
companies we invest in but just really
true for any company
um you know 80 90 95
of your content is stuff that is related
to
your vision and your mission and stuff
that people find useful
um you know the next step after content
marketing are you know
videos that are helpful all the type of
stuff which which kind of tech has
already been doing
right yeah um but what what is a new
concept is that
five percent of the time or one percent
of the time you're going to get a scrap
uh where your company's reputation or
brand is being attacked
by often corporate journalists for to
benefit their own companies
right because they get page views right
they they put your name which you've
built up over the years into their
headline and they get clicks
um and and they can literally make money
from that
because the anybody has right access to
your reputation they can debit from your
reputation
whereas they can't debit from your bank
account in the same way
um so the the distribution that you
build up
over years of providing useful content
to your followers
as a as a company can in that one
percent
uh case be used to actually fight back
um
because that's how you have you know a
million or whatever million followers
at that time so every company media
company build your own distribution
to avoid distortion relate to this you
know the tech industry we've talked
about learn to code you know what comes
after learn to code
what learn to write report publish and
direct